[Music]
when dangerous storms approach most
people flee
not 21 year old jonas pientech his
popular lightning photographs result
from staying put in the face of certain
danger lake maracaybo and the tombow
storms is one of the greatest
experiences you will ever get sitting
here at night watching the stars with
continuous lightning flashing all around
you getting hit by some really strong
storms the thunder the lightning that's
what makes this place so special for me
lake maracaibo venezuela is the
lightning capital of the world
where locals know the near daily
phenomena as the never-ending storm the
menacing atmosphere ignites piontech's
passion and creativity electrified he
snaps away striving to capture the
weather's beauty one flash at a time
i started with photography in 2011 when
i found out that my dad has a very good
camera so i just grabbed it went outside
and shot everything my interest in
weather started the same year as my
interest started in photography when a
tornado ravaged parts of a town close to
my hometown
i started to search for for pictures and
found some people out of my city that
are actually hunting for storms that are
chasing those storms and i started
riding along with them seeing and
experiencing everything they were
experiencing jonas is a surprising young
man that was one cool storm i just love
these bolts shooting down that is cool
his ability as a photographer and the
way he's centered for his age is pretty
impressive
being published in great magazines such
as the new york times is a great feeling
for me because i think people
acknowledge my work and people like my
work and what i like about shooting
weather is you won't get the same
picture twice the weather is changing so
quickly especially when you have storms
out there that you basically have one
chance to get the picture you want jonas
has been captured by something very
similar that i was captured by more than
20 years ago it's an enormous passion
for what happens here
lake maracaibo is a place that not many
people have traveled to yet such an
amazing combination of wildlife of
culture and of course this spectacular
phenomenon of lightning this is probably
my favorite place on this planet
the catatumbo lightning is like a
creature it's something that appears
every night actually just 30 kilometers
in that direction is the one point on
earth with most lightning strikes these
lightning strikes reach 250 per square
kilometer per year you have to treat
lightning with respect and you have to
consider if a storm is far enough away
to actually get the shots you want when
the storm starts closing in you have to
decide if you should move in and take
shelter the weather shifts in just half
a minute
generally the storm it's not only the
lightning it's also sometimes hurricane
force winds tornadoes all sorts of
formations of clouds and very heavy rain
one could describe this place turns to
hell at night for some people of course
it's amazing for me but there's so much
lightning so much storms around
lightning is the pure force of nature
it's something that is actually
dangerous but beautiful together
this lightning phenomenon here is just
the perfect topography it's an enormous
body of very very warm water
approximately 16 17 000 kilometers of
warm very low-lying water and it's
totally surrounded by mountains on this
map here
you can actually see by satellite the
image of the storms forming and you have
the end is almost going around the whole
lake and they will start pushing down
the cold wind at night towards the lake
which creates this special atmospheric
condition to actually produce extremely
intense lightning storms
the biggest challenge of shooting
lightning is to decide which aperture
you're going to use you have to do your
best to actually capture this whole
experience at once
but you will never really get the full
thing captured
capturing weather and capturing storms
especially is a great feeling because i
can share with the world what i'm
experiencing as a traveler as a storm
chaser and as someone who puts himself
into this danger to get the pictures and
the experience i want it's just
something that humanity can't influence
and you will feel very very small when
you're in front of a huge storm and
that's the best feeling for me that i
can possibly get
[Music]
you